[Music]
hey there welcome to honest trailer
commentaries where we were just talking
about guitar hero cuz we picked some
boring movies for this week and we did
something new this time I forget where
the idea came from was it before or
after we'd actually seen them
we had a empty week and nothing else to
do yeah big is opening this weekend yeah
unless we wanted to do in Australia for
Sicario didn't seem like fun and we were
debating between two movies neither of
which getting shot in front of your
family yeah someone's family in front of
you yeah awesome yeah really we thought
would support an honest trailer I'd seen
both of them and I was like fine
whatever it was off of your reaction of
like they're both okay they're okay and
I said well why don't we just lean into
that yeah and I agree with you after
seeing both of them I to be honest I
enjoyed both I they're fine they're fine
these were completely like big Hollywood
forgettable movies not offensive not
like on a story standpoint on an
expectation standpoint like I expected
to be entertained and I was you got it
and nothing but nothing of it it went
through me like Taco Bell it was like
yeah oh I'm enjoying this meat cheese
sludge and out it goes and it's gone I
think and I think probably my advice for
both of them was like recommend it but
I'm not gonna tell you not to go so and
if you don't like it I blame you the
viewer because these are the movies you
guys request you want us to do every big
movie that comes out and sometimes
there's just well we have to be honest
and there's not much to say about him so
this was our way of getting around
having night muchness I tried to like in
the draft phase I tried to because my
first idea was like okay I'll do a draft
from both and then we'll great hits and
I I think I was able to do like they're
usually what five six pages like an
average honest trailer and these were
about two and a half each and I was like
I'm tapped
[Laughter]
but surprisingly and we picked them at
random and yet there's some interesting
parallels yes I was very delighted when
I read what you guys have come up with
on this one it's like wow unconsciously
pick the two that actually sort of
complement each other
I guess there's just like and we will we
have actually mentioned this in the in
the deleted scenes that there's like a
kind of a formulated these things but
even the specifics of these two like
almost formulaic you would say they say
they're trying to please everybody and
thus no one yes
yeah so any other any other broad
thoughts about these two or should we
dive in this dive in let's just dive in
let's watch an Australians
[Music]
you enjoy a few parts of one and some
parts of the other but when two popcorn
movies are so aggressively okay there's
only enough to say about them to make
one honest trailer oh you're being
serious good clip on Pacific uprising
and Tomb Raider double feature
don't get mad we double these up you
know you were to see Black Panthers dead
anyway
these were two of the casualties I think
of the runaway phenomenal success of
Black Panther and that these were two
very big blockbusters that sort of got
caught in the wake yeah but I think
Pacific Rim opened above black I think
it was the first movie to then just drop
the Black Panther just a little waver
but it pretty much stayed on top for
like five or six weeks yeah exactly
so yeah you probably didn't see it did
you first time aren't you a do you think
we'll ever do this again the double
feature maybe it's kind of fun but I
think he had to pick the right - yeah I
think we got very we got real lucky at
picking two that were able to complement
each other the way that we did cuz we
we've done a version of this in the
sense that like will do a franchise
there's always serious films it's like
those those bargain bin DVDs - Matthew
McConaughey rom-com
tiptoes and toast - tip - so he's still
on his knees yeah tip - now he's on his
waist now even smart anyways let's keep
watching
there's dead anyway prepare for -
perfectly fine moderately entertaining
films that exist for the least exciting
reasons Time Warner's legal department
acquired an established IP from
Paramount and Comcast accountants notice
one of their movies over performed in
China the exact reason why there's a
Pacific Rim - are you saying but yeah we
can talk about it like the the reason
and we're about to make this point it's
like these movies aren't no one
approaches them with an idea for this
movie these are movies that they're
making and then they go out on us and
they assign them to write there's a
writer's pitch on them like all right so
this movie's being made
all right let's back our way into a
story idea and Pacific Rim I was sort of
like I was actually kind of psyched when
they said like oh it performed well
enough in China for there to be a sequel
because at that time gamble del Toro was
sort of like okay well I have some ideas
and four wise the specifics were a
male's Maelstrom and and you know he was
like okay I might do it but then when he
dropped out I was like and then this was
very much up uprising was what I thought
the first one was gonna be and I think
it really does show you what Guillermo
del Toro can bring to ya there's a
weirdness there's a depth to the sets
and just like literally the way it's lit
is better like just technically it just
looks like a real world and this one
looks like a video game it well it looks
it looks it's the CG version of like the
old Godzilla movies just like so
brightly lit and just like running
around these cityscapes and it's really
just man in suit but computerized and
and it just I thought what was great
over centigram was the the weird style
that he gave it and then just kind of
dark yeah it's a the I feel like Pacific
Rim one like the camera was like
catching this action as it happened and
in this one they're like posing for the
camera yeah I think that was that was
how the robots moved it just seemed
kinda artificial and they're designed to
ruin cities they are there's one with a
giant ball and chain yeah it's like
missing fist that it just swings around
and knocks over buildings so the fact
that we won't get into practicality
Pacific Rim it's that's aesthetic as a
whole but you all right del Toro like to
go back to he really elevated that Taco
Bell menu yeah cuz without him it is
just the taco but he's like I don't know
what's the best thing Taco Bell has the
volcano menu
he was the volcano menu and without it
it's just garbage well said Jeff yes in
China it's good you know someone had a
new story to tell or something to say
about the world or yeah
I know I sound like my grandpa I'll just
be in the shed suit up with two beats
working their butts off to make these
franchises a thing as they both battle
severe daddy issues and Japanese
MacGuffins in two films that start with
fun opening sequences descent into
by-the-numbers action and end with a
tease for a sequel that'll probably
never come to them next time we're gonna
come for them I'll take two I'm good
thanks I actually like Tomb Raider until
she went in the tomb and started raiding
it yeah everything up until the tomb
raiding yeah I do think that that was
like especially before she even goes on
the journey like the introduction of her
as like I don't know like a real person
she felt like a real person yeah and she
got exceedingly less real as the movie
yeah yeah you start with that opening
that really great opening like sparring
fight scene where she gets her ass
handed to you yeah yeah it really
grounds her and and I think that John
boyega boy Yaga and Alicia vikander also
Alicia vikander also have in common i I
enjoyed their performances yes I thought
they did well with the material they
were given their there they're talented
actors but just sort of put into very
bland generic movies yeah I honestly I
think we say like I would watch the
Laura Croft like living a normal life
maybe going on some type of like
adventure but it doesn't have to be in a
tomb yeah and they did that dumb thing
with the I'll take to where they put
that in the trailer and it's the last
line of the movie and I hate that yeah I
hate when they put it in the trailer and
it's like I'll take two credits and like
no you
you sold the movie that's false that is
false advertising because that was in
the trailer it was like yes he fanboys
he's got the guns and it's gonna be but
it's like no it's the end of this the
last line of the movie very very it's
like a it's not post credit but it's
definitely like post title the things
over yeah yeah it's like after the yeah
you're right does the credits and then
she goes in and talks to Nick Frost
again because I remember watching the
movie and I was like oh they cut the
I'll take to scene and then they go
Billy and I'm like
yeah yeah well hoodwinked again it was
one thanks
now that Oscar winner Guillermo del Toro
Ron Perlman and Charlie Hunnam are gone
Ronis in degree beckon a reluctant
mentor to the next generation very
reluctant as he was a credit record shut
up when he sent secret information from
a dead family member he'll team up with
an assortment of heroic Chinese people
to some puzzle by the way I looked up
the box office I couldn't figure out a
way to work this in but it was like you
look at the place where Pacific Rim did
the most business and it was like China
Russia Mexico like the internationally
there were new characters surprise
surprise there's a Russian subplot
there's Flores now it was just if you go
down the line South Korea there's a
Korean character introduced like Japan
they I mean they know their audience I
guess and they but the fact that it
matched perfect perfectly absolutely
perfectly perfect man even like screen
time sort of descended by yes by
box-office rating yeah yeah but we're
gonna have to get used to that you know
the it's a bigger and bigger market it's
a global market Spencer it's a global
market and it does make more sense in
your international robot movie although
transformers was that too but then they
put like a Chinese ATM in Texas no - no
they put Chinese people at Pacific Rim
proud of these they put Chinese products
there's a difference very different yeah
yeah yeah I don't mind it it just just
just don't make it so ham-handed and
sort of you know yeah Grimm didn't
bother me it made a little bit more
sense and particularly why they made
that movie which was because it did so
well in China but sometimes there are
movies that I'm just like even like age
of Ultron is like let's go to South
Korea like oh they're always going to
create Marvel movies yeah lucrative
box-office market for the for them like
the the the the Marvel movies do great
but at this point
in universe Korea must hate the Marvel
super straight yeah
all right buddy how do you feel about
superheroes let us know in the comments
below all right keep going to save the
world and super impractical robot
battles that are so insanely destructive
there won't be much of a world left to
live in either way now that Angelina
Jolie Jon Voight and Jorah Mormont's God
we're left with Laura Croft fit and
orphan who gets in over her head way
over her head when she said secret
information from a dead family member
she'll team up with an assortment of
heroic Chinese people but you find one
gun one knife on huh then save the world
and a super impractical tomb that's so
generic you'll wish they left her as
Laura Croft GrubHub delivery biker you
know anyone can read a tomb hitting
Chipotle from midtown to the Bronx and
20 minutes or less oh that is exciting
New Yorkers they're like it's a boss I'm
sure we'll find out the actual logistics
of that we pulled two neighborhoods that
roughly correct maybe we should have
said Brooklyn I don't know I don't know
and we'll find out we'll find out but
you know New Yorkers aren't gonna like
give their opinion loudly and forcefully
okay that's the spirit of the comments
I'm sure geographically that's probably
midtown to the Bronx would ya the tomb I
don't want to hammer on it too much but
the tomb itself it's boring it just felt
like obligatory every room and it felt
like okay here's the collapsing floor
room here's the spike room yep here's
the paint-by-number room are we out of
things to do in tombs there's only so
many things you can do anything they can
die there which is not gonna happen here
you can put in a bunch of traps I think
we were out of stuff to do in tombs with
the Last Crusade yeah I think that was
yeah we finished cleaned it out they
cleaned it out you know yeah I would
almost go the suicide squad route of
just like you know I'll just break
everything and then they do break a lot
of stuff - in the - oh yeah
some are poor archaeologists are like I
understand that there was a whole demon
plague thing going on
but guys that was this movie yeah but
like this would completely upend all of
Japan's history there was like a secret
Empress who like would had a magic
plague hand you think that you know some
what some historians would be curious
about this magic plague and there'd be a
couple of YouTube videos with a crazy
guy that's just like no Empress plague
han you don't get it it's all connected
yeah the plan is a metaphor yeah save it
for the second one
oh yeah yeah and they spent well I
talked about this earlier that they
spent the whole movie distancing itself
like this isn't the Laura Croft
Angele Angele version yeah here's the
shortest cargo shorts anyway let's keep
going a shower see no sense are exactly
alike gone is the female objectification
rate there's your shelters yeah except
the slag eyes front
and cos and one as a villain too drab to
be interesting while the other as a
villain too silly to be believed I'm
ending the world right I do love the
idea of Charlie Day being an enormous
celebrity in China I hope it's true if
you're trying to tell this is Charlie
take one of your biggest celebrities
because I only know him and love him
from Always Sunny in Philadelphia where
he's a little more innocent I feel like
than the other ones yeah but he does the
Charlie work he hits the rats with the
Charlie's with the rats dick I hope he
is I hope he's endorsing products I hope
some talk shows make that money charlie
yeah yeah I was really sad when we
realized that he was being controlled by
the alien brain I wanted it to just be
he was in an innocent relationship with
the in it with the alien brain and host
like promising him stuff yeah you had to
get really in these really sad we find
out that it's true yeah I'm a dunce the
whole time yeah a dunce just banging an
alien pretty yeah that's a good reveal I
liked that moment that was great yeah
anyways keep going
we're uprising would have been better if
it was more grounded in reality
while Tomb Raider would have been better
with a little more fun or three big
dinosaurs or
something stands the games over the next
time all the new releases are checked
out at box you accidentally leave
effects on on a Sunday afternoon you
can't go wrong settling on the movie
based on the video game that was trying
to look like a movie or the movie trying
as hard as it possibly can to look like
a video game either way you're gonna
have an okay time these days okay well
do just fine story through the shoe his
third by the rules military character in
six movies possibly that this movie pass
to the grim fest eight and Suicide Squad
yeah anyways I do i Scott Eastwood is I
forget that he's in these filming I
don't know if it's his fault I think he
just takes the very character that has
nothing to do it would be like come on
guys yeah do we all have Scott Eastwood
specific face-blindness I do I think
he's the average of every white face
yeah maybe so I mean he's good lucky so
every actor uh just kind of averaged out
all that it's that just softens it's me
the actor we're here to audition for
part yeah I am actor here to play man
should I sound wine anyways you've gone
very Karen six movies crash band across
a waste of a perfectly good
Rinku all voice no principles Vick daddy
paws that was a conversation who where
we recognize Walton Goggins from yes
Spencer you yours was vice principal and
Joe and I even though I've never seen
justified I know him as the guy from
justified so yeah yeah I thought of him
as the hilarious guy going against Danny
McBride but late by the way wait watch
Vice Principals and I hear justified
great I guess he's good and everything
yeah its second movie this year though
to waste him a major under the death
cure oh he was an amazing way stood him
and wasted in the scar and a good and a
good honest court masturbated in the
school did he last in the squad that
license huh and like a great like
grotesque makeup job and then they just
gave him a character that was just like
so nothing I'm sure in the books he was
obviously important so like wasted in
Maze Runner and and I thought again he
didn't do anything wrong in the movie
they just it was like let's get a great
actor and make him play bad man yeah he
didn't want to be there he just wanted
to get it done so we could go home and
like I know in one sense that that did
make him like sympathetic but in ever
since he's just like he's just over it
yeah your villain is over it the whole
time it's also the I realized after
finishing the plot is the first season
of arrow Oh dead father says you get you
lost on island where there's a thing and
there's a bunch of bad guys already on
inescapable island that would like to
leave but can't until they find the
thing and then you shoot them with a bow
and arrow
yeah did they do the scene in Tomb
Raider I've already forgotten where she
walks into the building and she's like
I'd like to see so-and-so and they're
like you can't see so-and-so and what's
your name and she's like Croft and then
they isn't the person who goes oh they
did an iron fist and they did and what's
the other one that is also like iron
fist where they walk in just like I am I
am Bruce Wayne did it Bruce Wayne did it
she did it there's another one where
they walk into the corporation to do
that super cut like I am my name is on
the Builder names it's on the building
[Music]
it's in and they look at the camera link
yeah better times
keep going no principles Big Daddy
wealthy Master Chief Woods tiny Stark
and burn gorman that sounds like a
parody name but nope his name is asking
burn gorman such a great name discount
Eddie Redmayne is my favorite the only
ones who cross Tomb Raider with another
movie the poster mixed it with Jurassic
Park but Allen lasted a week we couldn't
help ourselves we forgot about the
posters
one week I don't think I didn't write
Alan who did Alan Kevin all right each
lame our editor I did it
no it wasn't us this time although we
definitely approved it first
post-production include it's all a
family here but but yeah no one here on
camera thought of it but we all approved
it we all saw total area so we're will
Alan show up next week who knows who
knows like Carmen Sandiego yeah you will
yeah it's like our wilheim scream hidden
Alan in every trailer yeah no one is it
underneath BAM yeah you try yeah hit
mallas let's do it yep Alan did you find
the hidden Alan yeah we're all the
hidden Alan's our winner we're like
James Gunn we won't tell you where to
look but we'll confirm it if you found
it yes right sweet I'll try to remember
that
let's see simply it seems it's almost
like they've been forced into some safe
middle ground that's trying to please
everyone but doesn't really connect with
anyone hmm
starring dead boy Yaga charlie ho-hum
and Croft Bandicoot you sound like
you're comes undone
what just the sky the hateful one a
waste of a perfectly good Goggins goggly
eyes survivor man and a live wire from
the wire civic raid uprising theater on
Pacific tomb operated
Black Widow I would like to do this
super kind paws look out because yeah
there's the there's definitely worthy of
a super guys the leg scissors but the
actual line was so bad is that what she
say well you know where I learned that
the street the streets look I haven't
been in a lot of street fights but I do
watch a fair amount of WorldStarHipHop
and I do fine no one has ever thrown the
leg scissor that the cartwheel up to the
leg scissors in a street fight anytime I
do a system from the streets
I just think of Tobias auditioning and
rest of the rest of development saying
like I come from the streets and I'm the
last guy yeah I don't think anyone you
might have learned that in step up to
the streets yeah seems a little dancey
yeah yeah at no point in self-defense
stuff has anyone been like here's the
first thing you're gonna do you're gonna
jump up and grab their neck with your
legs a little spinning then use that
momentum to back spring if now if
there's like one fight choreographer in
the past five years that like that's
their one thing and it blew up and
they're just getting work everywhere
like more power to you yeah but the lady
do head spinnings gotta go had a good
run had a really good anything to do
with legs and heads waist scissor I
don't know deserve something else okay
moving on you're on fire there's a new
hero who's always getting hurt and
constantly running mmm-hmm no but she
does a lot of running in that yeah a lot
of things I like Alicia vikander I like
I like John boyega I like Pacific Rim
and I'd say and I like Tomb Raider but
that's it I like it yeah I don't love it
I don't hate it I like it
oh won't watch them again yeah I think
the FX
now humeid is like it's that kind of
movie if you haven't seen it you see it
on cable not a waste of your time
not a waste you have nothing else to do
yeah what's the ultimate on FX afternoon
movie tremors it's mean we leave FX on
quite a bit it's like somehow we turn
the TV on and 22 Jump Street every
single weekend but I feel like you have
to watch that you don't want to watch
that edited yeah Thor the dark world for
me is like that's perfect just like if
it's better than you might expect to see
but not what you would want to spend
your time on normally yeah that's a good
point
yeah yeah good point can't beat that one
for the dark world yeah it's good well
Sarah Matheny's I'm on a plane yeah I'm
on a boat uh we will be back next week
with another multiple movies in one
trailer but they're all a little bit
more related um and it'll be every man
for themselves when it comes out that's
right you know it'll be kind of wild
kind of dangerous do a countdown
yeah then get ready do a countdown
because people spend all year preparing
for this one yeah yeah that's right yeah
we're doing a lot of Christmas movies ah
nice misdirect we'll see you next week
here same time same place
monstro commentaries have a good
you
[Music]